what can we learn from products that
crash and burn a museum gives thanks to
ideas that tanked New York has opened
the Museum of failure
isn't it already
which you might know by its former name
CNN headquarters
you can stop by the gift shop for 20
bucks Chris Wallace will give you a foot
rub
and for an extra eight he'll give you a
CNN Plus
you know what that is huh
hold the peanut butter
actually you know what the place looks
like a lot of fun there's an entire Wing
dedicated to this guy
it's a gallery that showcases failed
products and services from around the
world stuff like Coke 2 Crystal Pepsi
Deloreans Google Glass and Bic for her
which was just a pen
but in sparkly colors
and it was also this is real Colgate
brand beef lasagna
sounds like a hit to me I won't have to
brush my teeth after I already I already
floss with their fettuccine
website explains that the museum aims to
stimulate productive discussion about
failure and Inspire us to take
meaningful risks and what better place
to celebrate failure than in a city run
by a Democrats
[Laughter]
cat uh this sounds like you might enjoy
this Museum uh what's your favorite
failure
any favorite failures that you should
would like to see in the museum
uh isn't this inspirational yeah it is
inspirational I I would I would like to
go to the museum just to feel better yes
usually it's the opposite yeah no no
like that's why you you know like I we
have all I've we I've had a lot of
failures you know throughout my life uh
and they like play in my head yes you
know at night so it'd be great when I'm
trying to go to sleep you know and uh I
feel like the museum I might have some
new ones in there but at least mine were
like mostly private I think I mean big
for her is amazing that to me is like my
favorite like I want to see the
commercial I look for it I couldn't find
it yeah it was like because girls need a
different pen all right like
having trouble writing words
finding it to be a bit too much for you
Joe it's interesting big for her tells
you something about just biology that
girls need to have happy little things
to keep them going while they do stuff
we'll just take a pen what sad things
keep me going yeah that's do you ever
want to go back to that cat no you don't
get up
Tyrus in a weird way aren't all museums
fake failure museums because like you
walk in and they got like ruins and you
know what's up animals yeah extinct
animals skeletons they're dead
[Laughter]
listen uh I'm a guy I don't need a
museum of failures I have a conversation
with my wife I don't need that oh
okay you ever have an argument
failures come up you don't you don't
need a museum for that just ask her
she'll tell you it's true yeah all the
women that's true disagree with her
she'll remind you the last time you were
wrong so but I think it's kind of mean
though so I failed okay me and my
buddies got together we decided to
design a pen just for girls
and we thought it was behind us yes and
that was what I'm saying I've moved on
with my life
the humiliation the bankruptcy
my other two creative friends killed
themselves
I decided to keep going on because
there's no way someone's going to
remember that and now
it's in a museum to make that feel
better yes
I do feel better
Michelle you being from the Sports World
I was I wanted to ask you what your
favorite failure was I was assuming you
might say the WNBA
hey that's women's fault though yes it
is they're not going here's support yeah
you know go to you know go to watch the
games it's still alive and kicking yeah
I used to call play-by-play on the WNBA
with Reggie Miller phenomenal thank you
I love Reggie Miller nice guy he's the
best good kid so true I mean that no I
mean it didn't go to Berkeley no he went
to UCLA uh forget it and his sister went
to it
he's a big Fourth Amendment guy yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was outstanding we should put that
in the failure Museum
yeah Brad didn't know what the fourth
amendment was we looked it up in the
break but anyway
um I like people's failures like actual
active failures like like Michael Jordan
always said I took 9 000 shots that
didn't go in right and but that made me
take the next one or Abraham Lincoln you
know talk about a shot
yeah but too soon yeah
well I I like the Thomas Edison all
these people who failed and failed and
failed before they succeeded I mean we
could could put Joe Biden in there
although he's still failing so I don't
know that but that would work because he
keeps standing on stairs so there would
be this the wing of failing upward right
exactly exactly I like people's failures
rather than product failures I think
those are more impacted I think mine
were mostly believing people who said
they love me oh yeah imagine how I felt
yeah
you know Jim uh is this your kind of you
would you go to this Museum I don't need
to go I could I could just talk to any
Millennial yeah
um
this there's already a museum of failure
in Brooklyn this will be the second one
that's when the Nets play at the
Barclays there we go
I'll go visit Madonna's plastic surgery
if I go
I'd like to see that
[Applause]
what's your biggest failure of a joke
have you ever told it what do you
remember
yeah I had an audition to write for um
uh David Letterman like that higher
Comics to set facts and jokes at the
time and they go give us a sample they
go just give us your best joke and I
thought this was the best joke I said I
that I um I spiked through so many girls
Windows I'm thinking about changing my
name to Tom
and I sent that in and I was like I'm
gonna get this writing job this is going
to be amazing like David Letterman is
going to say this joke
you know what's funny I wonder how
people don't remember what Tom means
probably do you keeping Tom oh there you
go yeah it was paper Tom yeah I also
know about the fourth amendment
is that weird because the Fourth
Amendment starts with someone peeping
into your window no I mean
wait a minute I don't want to get us in
trouble it's peeping person now right
yes yes
no Tom's a girl yeah
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else